Speaker 1: It is the world famous Friday mailbag.
If you have anything you want to say to me,
say it. You can email info at David Pakman dot
com. Don't abuse it. If you send emails regularly,
you've probably been flagged and filtered right
into the trash. Unfortunately, there are people
who send us dozens of emails a day, even five
a day. We just can't. We just can't handle it.
We have too many, too many emails coming in.
If you're if you're abusing it, unfortunately,
it's getting filtered, my friends. But let's
get into some of the messages that we did
get. Brian wrote in about an inaccuracy in
a video. David, your recent video conference
in Trump Failed Supreme Court Collapses has an
inaccuracy. Chief Justice Roberts took the bench
on September 29, 2005. This was after the
reelection of Bush, where he did win the popular
vote against Kerry by approximately 3 million
votes. The same can be said about Justice Alito
going on to say who assumed the bench in
2006. While I understand what you're saying
about the 2000 popular vote count. The claim
you made is partially partially inaccurate
and requires further context yet. So the. My point
was. Had Bush had the first election gone by,
the popular vote, Bush never would have been
president. And so, yes, this is true, that there
was another election which Bush did win, but which
Bush never would have been in the position of
being reelected had it not been for the electoral
rather than popular vote results in the year 2000.
Next email is from Marcos suggestion
for one and a half million subscribers.
Marcos says, I know you're going to reach that
milestone quite strongly as an act of powerful
celebration. I think you should shave your head
when you reach that goal. Yeah, like I honestly,
I would be willing to do that when we get to
1.5 million subscribers, but not just because
we get there, like we'll get there eventually.
The question is, is there anything we can do
to get there much more quickly? And I don't know
that promising to shave my head is actually going
to do it. One other idea that came in from Morris
was David on achieving 1.5 million subscribers.
Subscribers? May I suggest you do a live call and
ask it be on air. Now, what's funny about that is
in general, when we say doing a colonoscopy, we
mean the doctor does it, the patient receives it.
So I'm going to guess Morris thinks I should
receive a colonoscopy on air. But what he's
actually saying is I should perform one. And I
my specialty is podiatry. I could not possibly do
a colonoscopy that would be outside of my area
of expertize, but. It's an interesting idea,
nonetheless. The audience must be very confident
in me to suggest that Ryan wrote in about 2000
mules and says, David, do you plan on watching
or commenting on Dinesh D'Souza's 2000 mules?
My right wing coworkers have been talking about
it, and I'm looking forward to you dismantling
the claims made in the film. Ryan has actually
been leaving dozens of YouTube comments saying
the same thing. Ryan's obsessed with the film.
So I watched the sub. The quote, substantive
truth. The first two thirds of the film. It's
nonsense there. There's really nothing to refute.
The whole concept of the film is that using cell
phone, locate geolocation data. Which is not that
accurate. They pretend it's accurate, accurate
and extrapolate from that that there were people
trafficking massive dumps of ballots illegally on
Election Day in 2020. There's there's no actual
evidence presented. It's worthless. Don't waste
your time. It'll. It'll really rot your brain.
So, no, we are not going to be. We are not
going to be talking too much more about that.
Next, my pronunciation of Bangor, Maine. Sabrina
from Ellsworth, Maine, wrote in and said, There
is no error. It's or I pronounced it Bangor. And
Sabrina says, It's Bangor. I actually, you know,
99% of the time, my mispronunciations on this
show are purposeful. You know, Dan Bongino,
Tulsi Gabbard, etc.. I actually didn't remember
how to pronounce Bangor. I thought it might
have been Bangor. I apologize to anyone who was
offended. Thank you, Sabrina. Douglas wrote in
and says, Argument for prosecuting out-of-state
abortions. Could states that want to prosecute
its citizens for out-of-state abortions try
to argue that it's the same as if California
made murder legal and someone took their
child to California, murdered the child,
and then came back to their home state? Well,
you could argue that, but generally speaking,
states can only prosecute crimes committed in
their jurisdiction, in their jurisdiction. So
if murder were legal in California, generally
speaking, if you take your kid to California
and kill them where it's legal and then you go
back to wherever, Nebraska, where it's illegal.
Nebraska can't prosecute you for a crime
that happened outside of its jurisdiction. So
it's an interesting question. It
just doesn't work the way I think,
Douglas. You may think it does. It's also kind
of it's a very depressing example, I should say.
Katherine wrote in is miscarriage, manslaughter,
then, David, a fetus is have rights. Then doesn't
it follow that they have rights to due process?
It would be incredibly evil, but any miscarriage
ought to be investigated on the behalf of
the miscarried fetus. Did would be mama miss
her vitamins. Did she travel against doctor's
advice? Did would be papa slam on the brakes
while speeding, causing mama seatbelt trauma.
Most miscarriages can, in many cases be shown
to be a parent legally at fault. If the fetus
has a right to life and due process in the case
of death. Incredibly evil. But it's exactly what
they're arguing for, isn't it? Catherine, in many
cases, in many senses, it is. In many senses it
is. And listen, we played a clip on our Monday
show from someone that Luke Beasley interviewed at
the Trump event over the weekend who said mothers
who get an abortion should get the death
penalty. They believe abortion is murder.
The mother is the murderer. In Texas, they have
the death penalty. So that's it. Murder being put,
put to death, the mother. And unfortunately, these
are exactly the types of things. I mean, listen,
last week we played a clip about right wingers
expecting to start to see the death penalty for
abortion providers as well. So that's exactly what
they're pointing to. And it's quite horrifying.
Next. The email is from Christopher. Christopher
says You are unapologetically using the tools you
decry. David Many of us are aware you're
employing the slippery slope in your ROH
coverage and yet some two months ago you expose
the slippery slope for what it is a fallacy.
Here's a link to that video for reference. What's
up with that? Chris The fallacy is wrongly talking
about a slippery slope in the same way that appeal
to authority isn't a fallacy. If we're actually
dealing with an authority in the subject matter,
the fact that the slippery slope fallacy exists
doesn't make it fallacious when it's accurate.
And within days of the leaked Roe v Wade ruling,
you had all sorts of anti-choice activists talking
about, we've got to start prosecuting the moms
and we've got to prosecute the abortion doctors.
Greg Abbott in Texas saying we've got to reverse
the Supreme Court decision that allows the
children of undocumented immigrants to go to
public school. They want to do away with that
because, listen, if you can do away Roe v Wade,
you can do away with that. There again, talking
about gay marriage and saying gay marriage was
just as wrongly decided. We've now had a dozen
examples. So the slippery slope is not a fallacy
when it's happening, when it's happening, and
it is already a username, truth and more Truth
wrote on YouTube. I just don't get how
someone like Alex Jones has any supporters.
How? Who is this stupid? WWE actors are more
believable. He admitted it's all an act in court.
He could be wearing a shirt that says I'm fake.
I'm using you. You're stupid if you believe me.
And people will still follow him. That's
absolutely true. That's and we see that
with a lot of the Trump ist type cult
where it's they could they could just lie.
I'm sorry, they could tell the truth, exposing
that it's all a grift. And they would still have
followers. And you know how they would rationalize
it? They would go. Alex Jones had to say that in
court. He's not really playing a character. He
had to say it in court because otherwise they
were going to get him. But he really believes
this stuff he says. Now, I don't actually know.
Alex Jones may well believe the things he said.
I've gone back and forth over the years about
which it is. Brian wrote in about me. This
loser is still on YouTube. This channel is
trash. David Pakman has an IQ of a tennis ball,
but that would be an insult to the ball itself.
Your channel sucks. David Pakman sucks. He doesn't
covered anything realistic. This show is all B.S.
all day, every day, just like David Pakman face
is. And then I think that's the vomit emoji.
Brian, remember, you don't have to watch this
show. It's optional. It's optional. You don't have
to be here. My recommendation continues to be,
if you don't like the show, don't watch the show.
I know it's a novel thing. And also, by the way,
you don't have to comment about everything I say.
Like you don't have to email me because I said
something you disagree with. You could just go,
Oh, yeah, I disagree with that. I'm going to get
back to work or whatever the case may be. It's an
option. It's an option. It is available to you.
We have a great bonus show for you today. Sign
up at join Pacman Dotcom. Speaking of Alex Jones,
Jones would tell you not to get the bonus show.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money. Everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: He doesn't like it, but I
do. And so I encourage you to sign up at join
Comic-Con, get the bonus show. We'll see you then.